foreign
we're here at Google Cloud next with
Selena she just saw the workspace and do
it AI demo and she's going to tell us
her thoughts hi I'm Selena Culpepper I
am the director of Technology product
Innovation for Owens and minor and I
love what I've seen so far I love the
ease of use and just the intuitive
nature of all of these tools that will
make it so much simpler for us to be
able to get work done quickly wow that's
inspiring to hear honestly so can you
tell me a little bit about what your
favorite part of the demo that you saw I
think the presentation mode how it
intuitively captures what's going on in
the meeting it makes it possible for you
to be able to focus on what you're doing
and not necessarily taking notes the
fact that there are citations and ways
that it will draw out the important
parts of what was discussed and serve
that up in a really easy way that can be
shared is really impressive what did you
think about the image generation for the
slide decks or even the backgrounds I
can see so many uses for that in our
Arena we work in healthcare and so we're
looking at Innovation right now that
will make it possible for us to render
what products look like and how they're
used in those very important spaces
where attention needs to be focused and
precise how can we make it easier for
healthcare professionals to do what they
do best and save lives so I could
definitely see an implementation in our
world absolutely Healthcare is a space
where efficiency actually leads to you
know
yeah so that's so wonderful to hear
anything else that you thought was
really off the charts in the workspace
uh Booth here yeah I think there's just
a limitless opportunity for us to take
this home digest it and then incorporate
it into Healthcare in ways that the
world has not yet seen so we'll see
what's to come thank you so much for
speaking with us I hope you have a great
time at the rest of the next conference
enjoy yourself thanks
[Music]